Et allez, les rondelles ! C'est quoi, c'est le festival ici ou quoi ?
La rondelle, le trou du cul comme ça là...
Pardon...
Qu'est-ce qui te prend ?
En plus moi je croyais que t'étais...
Qui c'est qui tape là ?
Oh putain, merde !
T'as tapé sur ma main putain...
Est un livre sans gluten...
Excusez-moi...
Il y a pas de gluten...
Dans un bouquin...
Pardon.
J'en ai pris putain !
Putain de sa mère !
J'ai pas fait le temps et il y a quelqu'un qui a pété.
Ok, blah !
Un petit câlin...
Un, deux, trois.
Ah l'enfoiré...
C'est son titre honorifique.
Non mais...
Cercei, Khaalesi...
Ah non.
Non, arrête.
Elle s'appelle Daenerys.
Pardon.
Mon perso a la main gauche atrophiée...
Prout ?
Vous êtes au courant qu'on est le 16 du mois ?
Et alors ?
Et alors quoi ?
C'est moi qui connais pas mon texte ?
C'est moi, c'est moi...
Vous tenez vraiment à ce que je la bute, c'est ça ?!
C'est ça que vous voulez hein ?!
C'est ce que vous cherchez ?!
Pas du tout.
C'est une couille ou ta bite que je sens ?
Attends c'est trop gênant...
Maman n'est pas morte.
Maman ?
Non.
Tu pues de la gueule !
Tu comprends ça ?
Non ne ris pas...
Silence !
I kill you !
La semaine prochaine nous suivrons la fin tragique d'Erwan...
Un simple ingénieur du son sans problème.
De quoi ?!
Bonjour Erwan...
Du coup bienvenue chez... le monde... chez...
Chez les chtis !
Chez les chtis hein !
Après on est là hein...
Tu feras moins de l'humour au bout de ma kalash frère !
Prends-ton deux dans ta shneck !
C'est mieux ?